في جزيره بالي في اندونيسيا بتنعقد مجريات
قمه مجموعه العشرين واللي مواضيع
واجتماعاتها وبياناتها كلها ما حط اهتمام
الاعلام حول العالم
ومتصدره الاخبار ايضا والعناوين وطبعا
بيصير على هامش القمه عدد من الاجتماعات
واللقاءات والمؤتمرات وغيرها من اكثر
المقاطع تداولا من القمه خلال ليله امس هو
حديث ما بين الرئيس الصيني شيء جديد ورئيس
الوزراء الكندي
واللي ممكن نسميها يعني نوع من انواع
العتاب الرئاسي والعالمي
مباشر
احسن قنوات
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفتوا مشاهدينا امام الكاميرات
وعلى العالم الرئيس الصيني استعان بمترجم
لحتى يعاتب رئيس الوزراء الكندي وحتى يعني
وسائل اعلام وصفه الموضوع باكثر من عتاب
واعتبرته نوع من انواع التوبيخ فرائس
الصيني قالت رودو كيف هيك الي بنتكلم فيه
بيطلع للاعلام مباشره وعلى طول القصه
باختصار انه الصين وكندا اصلا علاقتهم مش
باحسن حالاتها ومن فتره وخلال القمه يوم
الثلاثاء تحديدا التقى الرئيس الصيني
برئيس الحكومه الكنديه لاول مره ومن وقت
لقائهم بالقمه الماضيه في 2019 وبعد
اللقاء الجديد في بالك انتشر في الاعلام
معلومات عن مضمون اللقاء بتقول انه
الزعيمين ناقش وغزوا روسيا لوكرانيا
وكوريا الشماليه وتغير المناخ ايضا وقالت
المعلومات كمان انه تريدوا اعبر للرئيس
الصيني عن خوفه من تدخل الصين في الانشطه
الداخليه الكنديه وهي المعلومات كلها
نقلها الاعلام نقل عن مسؤول كندي ما افصح
عن هويته هذه تصريحات هي اللي الرئيس
الصيني شيء كان بيعاتب تريده على تسريبها
وتردوا مثل ما شفتوه في الكليب رد عليه
لكن الموضوع ما وقف عندها هذا المقطع فمن
بعد تداول الاعلام له والحديث عنهم متحدثه
باسم الحكومه الصينيه علقت عليه وهاجمه
كندا
كونان كونان
مثل برده ما سمعته مشاهدينا المتحدث
الصينيه دفعت عن بلادها قالت احنا ما
بندخل بشؤون غيرنا لا كندا ولا غيرها
وصعدت في نهايه التصريحاتها واتهمت كندا
وترودو تحديدا بالتعالي رئيس الحكومه
الكنديه من جهه هو كمان ما سكت فمع انه رد
على الرئيس الصيني في المواجهه المصوره
فهو رجع سال عن الموضوع في مؤتمر صحفي
بعدها وتعليق وكان خلينا نقول اقل حد من
التصريح الصيني فقال انه ليست كل محادثه
سهله لكن من المهم الغايه انه نستمر في
الدفاع عن الاشياء المهمه للكنديين عموما
باختصار المقطع اللي انتشر والسجال اللي
دار بعده كل التطورات هذه كثار اعتبروها
انعكاس واضح جدا للعلاقات المتوتره اصلا
ما بين الصين وكندا
طبعا وعلى الرغم من انه روسيا ما لها لا
ناقه ولا جمل بكلها المواجهه اللي صارت
الا انه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه رفضه الا انه يكون الها بكل
عرس قرص زي ما بيقولوا فدخلت هي كمان على
الخط ونشرت على قناتها على تليغرام
الفيديو وعلقت انه والله الصينيين محظوظين
لانه تريدوا على الاقل ما صور وسجل وسر
بالكلام كامل مثل ما عمل مكان خلال محادثه
عبر الانترنت مع بوتن وقالت انه هيك
بيتعامل الناس اللي من غير شرف وكرامه
بحسب تعبيرها زخرفه هون تتلمع طبعا القصه
صارت فيه يوليو الماضي لما كان في محادثات
على الانترنت
و روسيا وقتها تمت فرنسا بتسريب مضمون
اللقاء عن طريق صحفيين دخلوا الاجتماع
لانهم مسؤولين في الوفد وسجلوا اللقاء
ونشره